The method to find the number of occurrences of any word is going to be pretty
similar to the one for occurrences of Alice. But instead of using specific
references to the word Alice, like Alice, and the length of Alice. It'll use
the given word, and the length of the given word. The calculation of the length
won't change. But the calculation of the length without the word will. Looks
like I need to actually take in a parameter. And now I return the length, minus
the length without the word. Over the length of the word. Let's add something
to our booktester, to test our new method. To check it we could compare it to
our answer for Alice. Looks like I didn't actually make a method occurrences
of. Ops. Occurrences of Alice. Should be more general. Hopefully now it'll
compile better. Here we know to expect 395 from before, and there's another
word that we checked how many times it occurs. We saw before that Mad Hatter
doesn't occur at all. Let's try this out. Looks like we got the answers we
expected.